the argument can be made that legalizing
polygamist marriage would be less
detrimental Society less detrimental to
society than legalizing gay marriage so
can the argument be made
that you can legalize a polygamist
marriage and that would be less
detrimental Society than gay marriage
they're really one two three a hundred
percent I thought I would say that at
least polygamy is real yeah at least
you're dealing with it's something that
God permitted yeah even if he didn't
like estimate yeah he wasn't into it
yeah but uh things kind of went awry
very often when guys not promoting it
you understand not saying we should be
doing it it doesn't violate the natural
laws
whereas the notion of same-sex marriage
is it's just an incoherent right phrase
I mean this this is why even to say
legalize same-sex marriage you can't
even if I wanted to legalize same-sex
marriage I feel so impelled to do so I
could not do that because it is not a
thing